شلل حركه طيران في امريكا يتصدر التراند
عالميا
وتذكره فوق الخيال لمباراه كاس موسم
الرياض اسم على مسمى مع وصول سعرها ل 9
مليون و300 الف ريال
وشركه تغرم كل من يزعج زملائه الموظفين في
اجازتهم اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
من الخبر اللي مكمل معنا من ايام الامير
هاري مذكراته ومقابلاته فما زال اسم
الامير هاري ومذكراته متصدرين الاخبار
والعناوين وان كان بسبب الفضايح والقنابل
والمفاجات اللي فجر عن العائله المالكي
فضح الدنيا فيها بصراحه
وبالجديد اليوم هو تصدر الكتاب قائمه
الكتب غير الروايه الاكثر ما بيعان في
المملكه المتحده وايضا تحقيق رقم قياسي
لبيع اكثر من 400,000 نسخه من المذكرات
سواء كانت ورقيه او الالكترونيه
طريقه عرض مكتبه بريطانيه لا نسخ مذكرات
الامير هاريسبير واللي مثل ما شايفينها
امامكم المكتبه عرض الكتاب على الرفوف
وبينهم حاطه روايه للمؤلفه بلا ماكي
بعنوان هاو تو كلير فاملي او كيف تقتل
عائلتك
يعني كله رمي حكي ووو بس يعني بطريقه
مدروسه بطريقه العرض خاصه مع الفضائح اللي
فضحها وفجرها في هذا الكتاب
ما اختفت بعرض الكتب بهذا الشكل بس همم
ولكن قالت انه عندنا نسخ احتياطي كثير من
كتاب احتياط لهاري يعني كمان لعبه ثانيه
من المكتبه على اسم الكتاب بصراحه عندهم
فريق تسويق شكله تعبان في التفكير والعصف
الدهني وما عنده افكار جديده وعموما اسلوب
العرض هذا انتشر حول العالم وتم تداوله
بشكل واسع بس مين نشر الصور واثار
الاهتمام يا ترى الاميره
عهد اليونان واللي نشرت الصوره على
الانستغرام من دون اي تعليق لكن ليش عمال
باقول لكم انه اعاده نشرها على الصوره كان
لافتت الاجابه هي لانه ببساطه الامير
وليام هو الاب الروحي او
الجعد فاذر زي ما بيسموه بالانجليزي الى
ابنها الامير
على كل حال على سيره التعليقات وردود على
المذكرات فما زالت القصر ملتزم الصمت وما
في اي رد رسمي تم تداوله لكن في معلومات
متداوله اليوم انه كامله زوجه الملك تشارج
اللي تكلم عنها هاري في مذكرات ووصفها
كمان اذا بتتذكروا بالشريره والخطيره وقال
انه هو واخوت وصل وابوهم علشان ما يتزوجها
المعلومات بتقول انه كامله مصابه بالذهول
والصدمه من اللي سمعته وانه هاري عمي
دمرته انه الكتاب في الكتاب من الانتقام
من العائله الملكيه وانه لو انه الملك راح
للزفت كانت لسه عايشه باللي في المذكرات
لكانت مدمرت تماما
من كم يوم اعلن رئيس هيئه الترفيه
المستشار تركي ال الشيخ عن مباراه غير شكل
ضمن الفعاليات موسم رياضه واسمها كاس موسم
الرياضه المباراه المقرره يوم 19 يناير
وراح تجمع نجوم فريقيا الهلال والنصر ضد
نادي باريس سان جيرمان
وستلعب على استاد الملك فهد الدولي يعني
بصراحه مباراه تاريخيه ونجوم تاريخيا راح
يشاركوا فيها رونالدو ميسي غير طبعا باقي
نجوم باريس سان جيرمان والهلال والنصر
طبيعي للاقبال على تذاكر راح يكون كثير
عليه لكن اللي صار كان بصراحه مش طبيعي
فطلبات التذاكر تجاوزت مليونين وطبعا
التذاكر خلصت المستشار تركي ال الشيخ مع
المباراه تاريخيه اعلن عن تذكره تاريخيا
كمان اسمها فوق الخيال مثل شعار موسم
الرياض السنه بالضبط وهاي مميزات التذكره
اسمع اهلا بالعالم هذه فرصتكم للمزايده
العمر الحدث الكروي الاكبر المرتقب مباراه
اكبر الفرق فريقي باريس سان جيرمان ونجوم
الهلال والنصر في يوم 19 يناير للشخص
المحظوظ تذكره فوق الخيال ميزاتها حضور
تتويج مباراه النجوم بجانب معالي المستشار
تركي ال الشيخ فرصه مقابله كريستيانو
رونالدو ميسي
ودخول غرفه ملابس الفريق الفائز بتذكره
سيشارك في حفله تتويج ويكون في الصوره
الجماعيه مع الفريق الفائز يبدا المزاد
بمليون ريال سعودي وبامكانكم المزايده على
المبلغ في حساب معالي المستشار تركي ال
الشيخ في تويتر وجميع دخل هذا المزاد يذهب
الى منصه احسان الخيريه المسؤوله عن جميع
الاعمال الخيريه في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
طلق المزاد السابع عشر من يناير الساعه
11:30 مساءا مقعدك ينتظرك لا تنسى
[موسيقى]
والمزاد مشاهدينا بدا من مليون ريال
وبدانا بعدها نسمع الارقام اثنين مليون
اثنين ونص مليون اربعه مليون سبعه مليون
وبعدين تسعه مليون والان السعر زي ما ذكرت
صارت تسعه مليون ريال و300,000
مثل ما شفت مشاهدينا كمان راح تشوفوا
امامكم الان شركه زوم قدمت عرض لشراء
تذكره ب 9 مليون و300 الف ريال كل هذا
ولسه على فكره زي ما سمعته قبل قليل باقي
على المزاد لسا سته ايام راح متابع طبعا
مع بعض ونشوف راح توصل او يوصل هذا الرقم
لوين
في صعوبه كبيره بوجهها الموظفين بانه
يحطوا خط فاصل ما بين العمل وقت الفراغ
وخاصه مع تطور وسائل التواصل امكانيه
الوصول للشخص وين مكان في اي زمان وفي اي
مكان وكثير من الموظفين بيتمنوا وقت
يطلعوا اجازه خلص ينفصلوا عن العمل تماما
ويعيشوا اجازتهم بكل تفاصيلهم لحظاتها
بصراحه الامنيه او الحل صار عند الشركه
هنديه للرياضات الخياليه اسمها دريم
سبورتس فرضت غرامي قدرها 1200 دولار
امريكي في حاله تصل احد الموظفين بزميله
اذا كان في اجازه وقال مؤسس الشركه
انه بيحل للموظف انه يبتعدو يتفصل عن نظام
الشركه لا مره واحده في العام من دون
رسائل ولا بريد الكتروني ولا حتى مكالمات
ولا شغل من البيت ولا غيره وعلى فكره
مشكله التواصل مع الموظفين اللي بيكونوا
في اجازاتهم السنويه من قبل عملي مشكله
رائعه ومش جديده وفي بعض الحكومات استخدم
في السابق قانون الحق في قطع الاتصال مثل
في فرنسا في عام 2017 وغيرها كمان من
الدول مثل اسبانيا وايطاليا والبرتغال
والمانيا واسكتلندا طبقه قواعد مماثله
بتجبر اصحاب العمل على تحديد متى يمكن ان
يكون الموظف خالي او خاليين الموظفين من
رسائل العمل
واحرار في اجازتهم تماما في وقت في في
كثير موظفين سعيدين ومرحبين بهذا النوع من
نوع من الاخبار لانه المفروض او يعني يحق
لهم انه ينفصلوا تماما عن العمل في وقت
الاجازه في ناس ثانيه وخصوصا من المختصين
في مجال الموارد البشريه شايفين انه
بصراحه موظفينها الايام صايرين دلوعي
مره بدهم اجازه الصحه والعافيه ومره بدهم
بيشتغلوا من البيت ومره بدهم ايام عمل اقل
وما حدا يزعجهم بالاجازه وغيره طلباتهم
كثرت كثير وكثار علق على خبرنا اليوم هذا
انه شو بصير يعني اذا زميلك احتاجك في
سؤال وانت اجازتك السنويه خربت الدنيا مع
بعضها
على كل حال لحتى نحكي اكثر عن هذا الموضوع
معنا من عمان دكتوره رولا عواد باسدودوخ
مختصه في الهندسه البشريه وموجهه شخصيه
ومهنيه اهلا فيك الدكتوره معنا همم دكتوره
يعني بدي اسالك بدايه السؤال اللي او ردته
قبل قليل هل واللي هو نابع من التعليقات
هل فعلا موظفين هالايام صايرين دلوعين
شويه زياده عن اللزوم والواحد يعني
بيعطيهم شويه حقوق بصيروا يطالبوا باكثر
صدقا هلا ما بنقدر نحكم عليهم بشكل قطعي
انهم دلوعين ولكن حقهم يعني حق الموظف حق
الانسان خلينا نحكي قبل ما يكون موظف انه
ينعم باجازه ينعم اييي يعني راحه نفسيه
وعقليه له لا يقدر ينتج ويعطي اكثر كمان
من ما هو ارضي عم يعطي وبينتج بمكانه
بالعمل فالافضل طبعا انه يحق له الاولويه
الحق له انه يكون في عنده اجازات يكون في
عنده وقت لراحته النفسيه ووقت راحت
الجسديه فانا لا ارى في ذلك اي دلع صراحه
طيب لدرجه انه يتغرم الموظف اللي مثلا عم
بينفذ شغل زميله اللي طالع اجازه ومثلا
وهي قد يعني عنده سؤال همم يعني اجابته
كثير مهمه لسير العمل هالقد يعني صعب انه
يسالوا سؤال يجاوبوا على طبعا وسائل
التواصل الحديث الان مش ضروري يزعجوا كثير
بدها غرامي 1200$
هلا لسؤال صغير لا ولكن هون يعني يقع
الموضوع على عاتق الموارد البشريه وعلى
عاتق الاداره انه بوضع يعني خطه اللي هي
سكتهن بلاني يسموها خطه واضحه انه مين
الشخص البديل في حال هاي الاجازه شو
المهمات او ال- ال- الاشياء اللي مطلوبه
من هذا الموظف خلي حدا بديل يقدر انه يقوم
بمقامه هل اذا كان الشيءك جدا مهم وما حدا
بيقدر غيره يتصرف هون في عندنا ضعف بيكون
همم بهذا الموضوع بيستكشن بلان الموجود
بالمؤسسه او الشركه وكمان هو بيقع على
عاطف الموظفين نفسهم فممكن احنا اذا ممكن
شخص موظف يعني يتمادى مش عم نحكي على سؤال
بسيط ممكن يتمادى همم انه كان الموظف
موجود على راس عمله يعني مش كانه في اجازه
يتعامل معه هون يحق له انه يتعاملوا معه
بطريقه انه يعطوه همم غرامه على همم
التصرف تبعه غير هيك كمان اذا الموظف نفسه
همم لازم يطلع هاي الاجازه يعني يفصل
تماما ما بين اا وظيفته ما بين حياته
الشخصيه خليه يقعد هالاسبوع يعني اذا عم
نحكي عن اسبوع احنا الاسبوع هذا لازم يكون
مرتب لو منظم لو مخطط له من ابل عشان يقدر
يعطي هاي الوظائف والمهمات اللي موجوده لا
الاشخاص اللي موجودين معه
خلال الاجازه هاي حق له طيب
ذكرت الفصل ما بين العمل وما بين الحياه
الشخصيه همم كمان التوازن ما بين هذول
الثنتين بنضلنا نسمع يعني في الفتره
الاخيره ورق لايف فعلا ما بينهم همم كثير
يعني مش عارفه ازاي احنا فاهمين ال- ال-
المصطلح غلط ولكن كيف نقدر نساوي ما بينهم
او نعمل ما بينهم بلنس اذا كان العمل هو
جزء من الحياه فاحنا هيك ممكن نقول مثلا
همم ورك اند فاعمل لي لايف فعلا مش لايف
هو جزء من الحياه مش كل الحياه
الورك لايف بلانس او التوازن او يعني
خلينا نحكي نوازن ما بين حياتنا المهنيه
وحياتنا الشخصيه هو انه ما تاثر كافيه على
الثانيه يعني انه ما تتاثر حياتي الشخصيه
او حياتي العائليه بوظيفتي مثلا بتاخر
كثير بالعمل مثلا الضغوطات اللي بتصير
عندي بالعمل كل هذا راح ياثر على حياتي
العائليه وبالتالي راح تتاثر على عملي
وعلى نفسيتي وكل الامور كل السير كان تبعد
حياتك لذلك لازم يكون في همم يعني توازن
نعمل توازن مش فصل للفصل مش موجود الفصل
كان موجود في كتب الاداره سابقا واضحك هذا
الشيء من يعني خلينا نحكي من ال 2017 وبعد
ذلك صار انه هو ما في فصل ما بنقدر نفصل
ولكن الشيء اللي بنقدر عليه انه ما نخليه
كف تتغلى على الاخرى ان كانت حياتي
العائليه على حياه المهنيه وفا سيرسا
العكس المشكله المه تقع عليها نعم اتفضل
هي المشكله انه الكلام جميل يعني من
الناحيه النظريه ولكن التطبيق صعب خصوصا
مع كثره المنافسه في ايامنا الحاليه يعني
في كل المهن وكل المجالات وهذا بيخلينا
مضطرين همم في بعض الاحيان انه نركز اكثر
على العمل من الحياه هذه الشخصيه على كل
حال شكرا ج- جزيلا لك دكتوره رولا عواد
بزادوغ مختصه في الهندسه البشريه وموجه
شخصيه ومهنيه كانت من عمان
الخبر الابرز مشاهدينا الساعات الماضيه
والشلل اللي صعب حركه الطيران في امريكا
بشكل كلي بسبب عطل قليل ف اداره الفيدرالي
اعلنت عن خطا في قنه عطل 12,000 رحله وقفت
كل الطيران في الاجواء واعلن السماح
للطائرات بالهبوط فقط ووقف اي اقلاع البيت
الابيض اكد انه للان ما في اي دليل على
انه الموضوع هو سبراني
سبب الهجوم بصراحه مشغول طبعا خبر مثل هذا
في دقائق
على تويتر شفنا اختصار اداره الطيران
الفيدرالي متصدره في امريكا وفي العالم
ومن بعد الخبر للان مثل ما واضح امامكم
زياده مهوله في البحث عن كلمه همم او
اداره الطيران الفيدراليه على جوجل حول
العالم
الطيران طبعا رجع لا طبيعته الموضوع
بالنسبه للمشاهد العادي يمكن غريب كثير
ومش مفهوم حقيقه وعلشان نحاول نفهم طلبنا
من الطيار صديقنا الكابتن ليث الرشيد يفسر
لنا وهذا كان رده
الحركه الطيران في الولايات المتحده
الخلل هو بسببها نظام يسمى النوت امس وهو
نظام اخبار
الطيارين ورجال الطيران باي اعمال صيانه
او اغلاق او تغيير على مدارج والمطارات
داخل الولايات المتحده هذا نظام هو نظام
التقنيه همم ممكن النظرين هيك موقع
الكتروني حاليا
تعطل لذلك لم تستطيع المطارات والمدارج في
الولايات المتحده الاخبار باي اعطال اي
تغييرات اي حركه تبيعيه في اي تدريبات
عسكريه في الاجواء او اعطال في الاضاءه او
في انظمه الاقلاع والهبوط داخل المطارات
تفصل لا يوجد علاقه بهذا النظام في
الطائرات نفسها
ولكن السبب همم ايقاف حاله الطيران وهو
الطيار لا يستطيع همم قيام برحله الى قبل
ان يتاكد من ان المطار في وجهته
عامل بشكل همم فني همم وامن
وتعرف عن ذلك يتم عن طريق الدخول الى هذا
النظام سواء الطيار يدخل الى هذا النظام
ويمر الى المطار والمطارات التي يريد
استخدامها ويتاكد من همم فعاليتها
همم في حاله هذا العطل همم لم يستطيع
الطيران الدخول الى هذا النظام بسبب تعطل
ولذلك تم ايقاف حركه الطيران والان بدات
تعود تدريجيا لوضعها السابقه
العطل فني تقرير كما قلت وهو قد يكون بسبب
هكر قد يكون بسبب تعطل نظام يكون فيه نفسه
او الاقمار الصناعيه والاتصالات لحد الان
لم يعرف السبب ولكن بداوا في اصلاح وبداوا
في همم
تحرك داخل المطارات هو اثر فعلا على
المطارات والرحلات الداخليه داخل الولايات
المتحده او الرحلات الخارجيه القادمه الى
الولايات المتحده اذا كان هناك رحله ذاهبه
الى خارج الولايات المتحده لا تتاثر لانه
بطبيعه الحال المطارات خارج الولايات
المتحده اخبرت بجميع معلومات على هذا
النظام ولم يكن هناك اي خبر فهو
عطل فني همم اثر على الحركه الداخليه ليس
بخطير من ناحيه امان على الطائرات ولكن
تمت السيطره عليه واتوقع خلال ساعه قناه
المسعود الحركه
المنصات في ليبيا حال كبير من الغضب
الشعبي بسبب مقطع فيديو من داخل مستشفى
مجدل عام في ليبيا واللي من صدر اسمها
ترند على الفيسبوك من امبارح مقطع الفيديو
هو بث مباشر لعمليه ولاده قيصريه لامراه
كانت مسافره من الجنوب الليبي للشمال
والطرت الى الولاده القيصريه في المستشفى
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله على سلامتهم يعني بس الفيديو
اللي شفتهم مشاهدينا تنبت اللايف على صفحه
مستشفى مازدا العام على فيسبوك من بدايه
العمليه لنهايتها ومنشور من دون اخفاء
للملامح ولكن احنا اضطرينا بصراحه انه
نخفيها احترام لخصوصيه الام والطفل كمان
اللايف هذا عمل حالك كبيره من الغضب
والجدل على المنطاد والناس استعجنت اللي
صار واعتبروه انتهاك لاخلاق المهنه ولا
حرمه المريض وطلبه وزاره الصحه الليبيه
باتخاد الاجراءات القانونيه اللازمه
والتحقيق مع الطاقه الطبي اللي صور
العمليه وفي ناس شافوا انه عادي اللي صار
والمريضه حبه تتشارك هاي اللحظات مع
عائلتها
ولكن من بعد الغضب الشعبي والمطالبات قام
المستشفى بحذف البث المباشر من صفحته على
فيسبوك نشعر بيان قال في انه تصوير عمليه
الولاده تم من بعد ما تم اخذ الاذن من
الام اللي هي طلبت انه يبثوه عمليه
الولاده مباشره كون عائلتها في الخارج
وحبوه يطمنوا عليها وعلى الطفل بينما وصف
مدير المستشفى علي الكباشي الحمل اللي
تعرض لها المستشفى من بعد البث بانها غير
منطقيه وان العمليه القيصريه مثلها مثل
غيرها من العمليات عادي بتلبسها وتوثيقها
بالصوت والصوره وقال انه طلاقم الطبيه عم
بتمر في حاله من الاحباط من بعد الهجمه
عليهم عبر السوشيال ميديا لكن على الرغم
من البيان والتبرير رده فعل الرافدين للي
صار هي اللي
وهيك مشاهدينا وصلنا على ختام هذه الحلقه
من تفاعلكم طبعا اذا اردته متابعه
فيديوهات حلقه اليوم واخبار اخرى وجهو
كامرات هواتفكم
الظاهر اسفل الشاشه وتفاعلكم يعود ويلقاكم
غدا باذن الله دائما ايضا لا تنسوا
العربيه دوت نت
شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]